Right,
well,
I,
I think that all of us who in some way
or Anglo Saxon a half to realize that
there are other ideas around,
um,
and that they can be added to our own
thinking and vocabulary and that we have
to be open minded towards others.
Now,
that doesn't mean that we give up
cultural basic assumptions such as human
rights,
such as the rights of women and children
because some of these basic assumptions
in our societies we must not give up and
we have to continue,
I think arguing and,
uh,
illustrating how they benefit society
when you pursue them.
But that doesn't mean that you cannot
collaborate with countries far away,
uh,
which are inspired by a global community
that is all the time learning from each
other,
from different corners of the world.
And we don't have to give up our
identity even if we open up to other
cultures and other assumptions.
Well,
I think the basic thing we identified
was that in the 19 eighties we had come
so far in seeing the dramatic and
emerging trends of the planet being
affected by our human activities that
we,
for the first time in human history,
we realized that we are not only
responsible for each other,
those who are living today,
but that we are responsible to take care
of the opportunities for future
generations.
That was the basic,
I think,
content of that observation and about
the concept of sustainable development
that we need to also considered the
future of coming generations,
you know,
in the 5,100 years ago,
people south about future generations
with regard to their own son or daughter
taking over the farm,
but they didn't have to sync a in terms
of the global,
uh,
aspects of our footprints with undermine
the future choices of generations.
Unborn.
That's,
I think is the basic part of that
concept.